hallo wir drehen heute eine neue episode
super easy german aus einer lagerhalle
im süden holen
wir sind hier mit einer gruppe von
logistikern die deutsch lernen wie heißt
du die scheiße auto was ist dein beruf
ich bin technischer abteilungsleiter und
wie heißt du ich weiß sogar und was ist
sein beruf ich bin abteilungsleiter
zentrallager leichtern abteilungsleiter
zentrallager leitstand das ist auch für
deutsche ein sehr schwieriges wort wie
heißt du dich heißt und was ist sein
beruf durch unterricht besser deutsch
und wie heißt du und was ist dein beruf
ich bin grade bereich weiter im lager
müssen wir helme tragen
thomas warum tragen wir diese helme
genüge sicherheit
wir tragen die helme für unsere
sicherheit woher kommen die waren in
diesem lager wie bei rentieren das
gelang gang kommen aus aller welt
wer liefert die waren an das lager
manche fordern gelangen anklage direkt
von den produzenten
er gibt auch solche waren die von den
internationalen vermieter gekommen
manche produzenten liefern die waren
direkt an das lager und manche waren
werden über internationale vermittler
anders lager geliefert welche sortimente
unterscheidet ihr wir haben drei
verschiedene 14 was zur verfügung das
feature finnland und offen und das
trockensortiment sind waren die nicht
gekühlt werden müssen das frische
sortiment sind waren die gekühlt werden
müssen und obst und gemüse kennt jeder
jetzt sind wir im trockensortiment in
der klopapier abteilung was ist das da
sind paletten
wie hoch ist die traglast einer palette
ungefähr 2 com eine palette kann
ungefähr zwei tonnen tragen eine tonne
1000 kilo was ist das das ist eine
hebebühne mit der hebebühne fahren wir
nach oben
wie hoch ist die hebebühne 5 meter die
hebebühne ist zwölf meter hoch wenn sie
voll ausgefahren ist jannis rollt auf
der hebebühne durch das lager ich mache
ein video von janus wie er auf der
hebebühne durch das lager fährt jetzt
wenn sie in der abteilung für obst und
gemüse
wie kommen die produkte von hier in den
markt liter milch
wie weit ist die strecke vom lager in
die märkte gut 40 kilometer und lenke
über 300 kilometer die lkw fahrern
unterschiedliche strecken zu den märkten
der nächste mag ist nur zehn kilometer
weit weg der weiteste mark der von
diesem lager ausgeliefert wird ist 300
kilometer weit weg jetzt sind wir im
frischesortiment lukas welche produkte
gibt es hier
wir haben milchprodukte und in der
frische abteilung gibt es nicht produkte
und fleisch jetzt sind wir in der
zeiteinteilung hier ist es sehr kalt
futter wie lange befinden sich die waren
durchschnittlich im lager im gefüllte
waren eli gerne im lager ta2 woche und
in diesen briefen und gekühlten waren
liga
die gekühlten waren werden schon nach
einem tag wieder ausgeliefert
lukas fährt mit dem gabelstapler er
fährt mit dem gabelstapler an die
paletten heran
lukas hebt die paletten mit dem
gabelstapler an
jetzt werden die paletten mit dem
gabelstapler nach oben gefahren
gabelstapler wieder nach unten gefahren
und mozart stellt die paletten wieder ab
das war super easy german auf einer
lagerhalle in gliwice polen
danke fürs mitmachen und danke fürs
zuschauen
[Musik]